ja willst du Youtuberin werden ich bin
Youtuber
[Musik]
hallo meine Freunde willkommen zum
zweiten Vlog Miss Video und damit zum
zweiten Advent ja beim letzten mal habe
ich die kleine Kerze als erstes
angemacht ich weiß nicht warum ich
dachte dass man das so machen muss aber
ihr habt absolut recht man fängt mit der
größten an ich hoffe euch geht es so gut
wie mir
[Musik]
da ich mich in dem ersten Block mit
Video so unfassbar hässlich gefühlt habe
habe ich mir heute noch mal mit meinem
Styling besonders Mühe gegeben und das
bedeutet dass das alles hier noch
gestellter aussieht als es eh schon war
diese Woche hat extrem unweihnachtlich
und langweilig angefangen denn ich
musste drei Cocktails die ballern
schneiden das was ihr jetzt am
Donnerstag hoffentlich schon gesehen
habt
und ja wenn man schneidet passiert nicht
viel außer dass man einem PC sitzt und
schneidet
hallo
4k Ultra HD Schmalz auf den Zehen nehme
[Musik]
ja brauche erstmal ne willkommen aus der
schnitthölle ich meine zentrale Schneide
gerade dieses Video und es ist sehr
viele totalen aber selbst die Rand
springen dauern so lange ich sitze für
eine Minute Videos sitze ich eine Stunde
hier gefühlt und das kann ja einfach
nicht sein ich weiß aber auch nicht was
ich besser machen könnte ich merke dass
meine Konzentrationsspanne immer für so
eine Stunde anhält und dann muss ich
ganz kurz was anderes machen in diesem
Fall pumpe ich mir Mandarin rein sind ja
immer noch hier in einem
weihnachtsformat ne und da müssen
einfach weihnachtliche Dinge passieren
das ist Pflicht happy Christmas habe ich
nicht geschrieben die Regeln
ist einfach so also ihr könnt mir nicht
erzählen wenn ich euch das Ding zeige
ihr wisst wie es riecht bzw eher das
hier man weiß einfach wie das gerade
weihnachtlich riecht aber eine Sache die
ich an Mandarin nie verstanden habe
warum schmecken sie am besten wenn es
draußen am kältesten ist klar sie sind
importiert aber wahrscheinlich müssen da
wo sie gerade wachsen einfach gerne Zeit
sein
trotzdem ist es ein bisschen merkwürdig
dass wenn man sie im Oktober kauft dass
sie einfach nicht so gut schmecken wie
im November das sind ganz böse series
die mich interessieren ich habe
herausgefunden warum ich dann doch so
eine schlechte Haut habe und es liegt an
der Sonne ich bin auf dem Weg nach Köln
in der Sonne eingeschlafen also im Auto
für fünf Minuten hat die Sonne komplett
auf mein Gesicht geschehen und danach
hatte ich einfach rote
Ausschläge und Flecken und es war nicht
nur aus wie ein bisschen Sonnenbrand
bekommen nee das war richtig komisches
ja ganz komisch allergisch saß aus und
was ich halt verrückt finde am Körper
habe ich eigentlich eine Haut die ist
überhaupt nicht auf die Sonne aller
erwischt so ich kann echt lange in der
Sonne sein ohne das was passiert Timo
konnte sich das letzte Video von der
Qualität kaum angucken deswegen hat er
mir jetzt die Kamera gegeben
und ja jetzt ist eindeutig ein besseres
Bild ich sehe auch ja
so muss man aussehen wenn man zu Hause
arbeitet heute ist Dienstag ich war in
den letzten beiden Tagen beim Sport ich
habe mir so zum Ziel gesetzt um das
zeige ich euch kurz kommt mit
ich habe ein Ziel ich habe mir letztes
Jahr was für Weihnachten gekauft was ich
anziehen wollte und es hat mir aber
schon letztes Jahr nicht so gut gepasst
und habe ich es doch nicht angezogen das
hier es ist ein offizielles Helene
Fischer Bühnen-Outfit und da möchte ich
reinpassen an Weihnachten oder an
Silvester das ist ich nehme bei ich
nehme beides mit Silvester könnte aber
blöd werden ich wahrscheinlich an
Weihnachten so viel gegessen habe dass
das dann schon wieder nicht passt das
bedeutet viel Sport wenig Karts und
vielleicht passe ich da in vier Wochen
rein wer weiß denn übrigens die
Adventskalender die ist nicht geschafft
haben
ich will nicht mehr
mitnehmen ich kann nicht mehr Hallo
mittlerweile 20 Uhr und ich schneide
immer noch
halte das alles nicht mehr aus hattest
du doch erstmal nicht fertig werden
ich werde ein bisschen verrückt was
haben wir denn hier ja haben wir dein
allseits beliebtes
es gibt nämlich dieses Jahr auf meinem
Kanal auf meinem asmr-kanal ein
Adventskalender wir machen jeden Tag
Video ich weiß nicht warum wir sie
Scheiße schon überlegt haben und wir
dachten es ist ganz gut wenn ich das
hier so vom Weihnachtsbaum mache Leute
man wird ja wohl noch träumen dürfen
eben naja ansonsten war der Tag sehr
langweilig und
eintönig und naja ich wünsch manchmal
jemand könnte für mich komplett die
ballern schneiden aber das geht halt
nicht aber eine Sache ist nur das ist
dazu das nur du in der Nacht Basti die
magischen Hände die Kater Hände die
lustigste Frau der Welt oh oh okay
gekauft
vitalisieren möchte nämlich ein seven
mal gucken wie das wie diese Pläne
laufen
[Musik]
gute Nacht
wir haben uns zum seven gucken eine
Kokosnuss gekostet aus der Kameras
trinken aber wir müssen draußen trinken
wie knossi
vitalisierend
geil holt euch eine Kokosnuss leute das
ist so geil die schmeckt aber wirklich
als ob der Zucker drin wäre
gar nicht geübt
es ist Dezember
fröhlichen ersten Dezember jetzt hat die
Weihnachtszeit offiziell gestartet
und was macht man am ersten Dezember
wann öffnet das erste Türchen von seinem
Advent
skalender ich habe dieses Jahr kein
richtiger Adventskalender aber ein
Adventskalender auf den ich noch echt
gewartet hatte kam
vorgestern an aber da hatte ich ja schon
kein Adventskalender mehr ausgepackt
ein Bubble Tea Adventskalender ich
glaube nicht dass ich ihn mögen werde
aber wir schauen mal es ist so komisch
dass ich jetzt einfach nur ein Türchen
aufmachen darf
die Komposition oh mein Gott
das ist so ein richtiger
oh ich weiß es
das ist doch der perfekte Platz
[Musik]
tja
ich meine es gab deutlich schönere
Adventskalender aber
why not Nummer eins also dieser Kalender
wird wirklich eine schöne Überraschung
aber ich weiß hier wirklich nicht was
drin steht also Bubble Tea aber okay
Kurier Maske
Zucker Wasser konzentrierte Dings mein
Schatzi Pulver also er fängt schon
ziemlich random an die ersten Türchen
naja vielleicht sind es am Ende gute
Zutaten für cockt jetzt die ballern wer
weiß was mich aber wirklich traurig
macht dass ich dieses Jahr keine ikea
hat wenn's Kalender habe
nachdem der anstrengende Teil dieser
Woche aber vorbei war habe ich mich mega
gefreut auf die Youtube
Weihnachtsfeier oh ich bin zusammen mit
Naomi hingefahren was mich sehr gefreut
hat denn ich hasse es alleine auf
solchen Events zu sein deine Nachbarn
meine Nachbarn gerade
Kamera
das ist eigentlich
nur noch rot und pink geworden
[Musik]
ich mache eine kleine roomtour hier ist
dein Adventskalender was wir heute im
ersten Türchen drin
oh na dann sind wir live dabei
war das erste schon was richtig krass da
habe ich meinen Kirschkernkissen von ihm
bekommen was er selber genäht hat
oh
okay Naomi what did you get in your
first Adventskalender Box number
one of you
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wen haben wir denn da
Youtube space sag mal Mutter Youtuberin
hier unterwegs Youtube hatten mega
schönes Event auf die Beine gestellt
einmal als Weihnachtsfeier und
zusätzlich weil es sie jetzt 15 Jahre
gibt happy Birthday Youtube happy
Birthday und vor Ort gab es einen
richtig schönen Weihnachtsmarkt
[Musik]
warum Filmen sie hier hallo das ist
Sally falls ihr sie nicht kennt hallo
wie viel zu viel zu tun ja
zusammen hier gemacht habe
hierher kommst du oder was der tut mir
leid
[Musik]
für die Kräfte
ich habe eigentlich weihnachtlich
geguckt ich weiß nicht was Du gerade
hast
[Musik]
hi hier ist Cassandra von JAM FM viel
Spaß beim Blog
[Musik]
ja bist du Youtuberin werden ich bin
Youtuber
wir werden jetzt hier gekippt auf eine
Spotify Party eigentlich war ich nicht
eingeladen aber
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir aber zu meinem
absoluten Highlight diese Woche und zwar
fahre ich nach York also York und
Buxtehude denn meine Schwester lebt Jan
Buxtehude mein Bruder lebt in York Anis
Eltern leben auch in York und wir
schlafen bei Anis Eltern was mich immer
mega freut weil es sich dann einfach
anfühlt als ob wir wieder 12 werden und
wir bei ihr übernachten und weil ich die
beste Tante aller Zeiten bin komme ich
natürlich nicht mit leeren Händen
sondern habe für alle meine Nichten und
Neffen und das sind ganz schön viele
Adventskalender mitgebracht verratet ihn
nicht dass das Adventskalender sind die
ich nicht mehr geschafft habe
auszupacken viele Gefühle haben
Schweigepflicht
und wieder sind wir on tour toll wir
freuen uns
ich wollte euch einmal zeigen das ganze
Auto ist voll mit Adventskalendern anni
wir haben eine weihnachtsmission
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
mal hallo na wie geht's euch
[Musik]
ich darf heute Weihnachtsmann spielen
zuerst ist Mama dran mama du bist dran
wirklich
Kalender
[Musik]
wer ist für Malik der Pokémon
2 aufmachen
tatsächlich noch nicht das sind
Lebkuchen Weg Männer Tannenbäume und
Schneeflocken
sehr gut Sonntag gibt's Kokosmakronen
auf blau Adventskalender
wie Mali schaffst du es so cool zu sein
hä ich bin nicht cool
natürlich bist du cool wie alt sind sie
9 Jahre alt neun Jahre alt was möchten
Sie von Beruf werden Fußballer
in welche Klasse gehen sie
sagt liebe Grüße
[Musik]
das haben wir auf Kamera das Team oder
nicht so
[Gelächter]
marco war dein Lava das war nicht meiner
wie kam der denn jetzt das ist mir
gesagt ich wollte Dir nur sagen ich
finde Dich geil so scheiße der hat doch
mal so die gemeinen Sachen zu mir gesagt
finde ich gar nicht so scheiße
im Traum wann wir arbeiten wann kann man
machen müssen
[Musik]
ja okay
aber es ist nicht zum Date gekommen
[Gelächter]
wer weiß wenn ich noch alles auf dem
Date gefragt habe Paulchen vielleicht
guten Morgen in diesem Haus ich habe gut
geschlafen ich habe viel zu lange
geschlafen aber ich finde in Anis altem
Kinderzimmer kann man auch einfach super
schlafen so damit jetzt richtig
verstanden habe ich muss jetzt in
Supermarkt und Kaffee kaufen hahaha Spaß
bei dem Rewe habe ich gearbeitet
hier arbeitet Abdul
der schuldet mir noch 5 Cent
das ist meine alte Schule da haben wir
Mathe gehabt
[Musik]
so einmal hier noch Hühner
das Henry wir sind gerade bei unserer
Freundin Julia in Stade und äh hier ist
so ein kleiner Weihnachtsmarkt den sie
unter ja in ihrer Garage oder Pavillon
irgendwie so machen und sie zeigt uns
gerade einfach Ihre Hühner und ich bin
nur neidisch auf diesen Lifestyle ist
aber ein Hahn oder
Julia die mit Rot auf dem Kopf sind die
anderen ist ein Hahn ne
das ist ach so ich dachte
oh mein gott
hat sieben Namen Frieda Frieda hallo
[Musik]
tschüss
und nach Monaten bekommt mein Bruder
endlich wieder seinen Auftritt hier ihr
habt ihn vermisst ich präsentiere euch
Kito ja kein Interview wie wie erlebst
du bis jetzt die Weihnachtszeit
warum freut sich am meisten jetzt heute
abend worauf freust Du nicht auf essen
okay worauf hast du Bock Bratwurst oder
so
[Musik]
süße Dezember
tolle Bilder davon
[Musik]
jetzt trinken wir auf Freundschaft okay
eins zwei
mit Amaretto
heute Abend
[Musik]
hallo wer bist du eigentlich aus dem
Youtube-Video von maiwane die schlimmste
Mutter der Welt genau oder das
Adventskalender Video ah ja ja
bitte deine Klasse
ich glaube wenn wir so machen dann sehen
wir nämlich gleich aus nee ich bin
dicker im Gesicht und machst du jetzt so
nah dran hör mal bitte ein Meter
hier war das schön aus dem David oh Gott
die kann das auch ach so Sally äh wir
kommen im Januar
wir kommen morgen zum adventsfrühstückt
also wenn es etwas gibt was ich in
Berlin extrem vermisse dann sind es
meine Geschwister also es wäre so schön
wenn sie wieder in meiner Nähe werden
denn jedes Mal wenn ich mit ihnen Zeit
verbringe lacht mein Herz und ich habe
das Gefühl ich bin irgendwie komplett
und wenn ich hier immer alleine bin dann
ja fehlt irgendwie so ein Teil ich meine
ich habe den tollsten Freund aller
Zeiten darüber brauche ich nicht reden
den seht ihr auch oft genug aber meine
Schwester die vermisse ich schon echt
immer toll deswegen freue ich mich um
jede Zeit die wir gemeinsam haben die
wird zusammen verbringen können und das
macht sie ja auch immer noch zu was
besonderes wir haben nie einen Alltag
zusammen sondern immer wenn wir uns
sehen dann ist es ein absolutes
Highlight und das war meine zweite Block
Miss Woche und die nächste Woche wird
unfassbar schön denn ich bin wieder in
einer anderen Stadt ich bin wieder on
Tour wieder zusammen mit Naomi sie ist
sehr präsent in diesem Block ist oder
ich habe gar nicht so viel Zeit in
letzter Zeit mit ihr verbracht und
dieses also jetzt kommt sie einfach ja
Dauer Naomi ihr könnt euch wieder auf
Sie freuen und ich wünsche Euch noch mal
einen wunderschönen zweiten Advent für
mich ist diese Zeit was ganz besonderes
ich hoffe ihr könnt sie auch ein
bisschen genießen und habt nicht allzu
viel Stress und jetzt seid ihr doch
hoffentlich also jetzt seid ihr doch
bitte wieder in Weihnachtsstimmung oder
jetzt aber
sexy